[Music]
it was like time Stood Still last night
as two legendary diva cher and Selene
stole the show at the Billboard Music
Awards I mean what they wore why they
performed it was an incredible night
also a big night for Drake and our
Cameron Mathison was backstage to
capture all the excitement and the
emotion
[Music]
I think the big winner tonight for me is
the crowd
a zillion marked a 20th anniversary of
her Titanic love song fans belted out my
heart will go on so loudly that she
actually thought something went wrong I
thought that it was a drop in my sound
and they said no it's because the people
you had the biggest choir in the whole
wide world it was a retouch ever did you
see that performance of your mom out
there yeah it was awesome very emotional
a special moment son Rene Charles watch
from backstage where the night's big
winner
fellow Canadian Drake was vowing an awe
of Celine hard to believe Rene Charles
is now 16 it's you man you're old
growing up it's Hannibal thank you honey
you start singing I'm only out of the
voice for it Oh we'll see all you ever
know I never know he's into music into
he's great in school I have to admit it
and talk about that but I'm very proud
of him and this icon clearly entertained
this one
we got Celine leaving a sing-along
backstage - icon award recipient share
when I was really young my mom said
you're not gonna be the smartest your
uncle be the prettiest you're not gonna
be the most talented but you're gonna be
special
it kept off the snap Chetty star's
birthday weekend turning back time again
in that sheer black mesh at 71 years old
Miley Cyrus was overcome by emotion
tearing up as she performed her new song
Malibu live for the first time as the
song she wrote about fiance Liam
Hemsworth and he was backstage
supporting her as was Miami's family who
had some fun moments my dad's here my
mom's here my sister Brandy's here like
it's just such an exciting night I just
love seeing everybody be happy that's
all I ever wanted for all my kids for
teachers everybody be happy and this guy
Josh Duhamel was clearly happy he
continually photobombing the Cyrus clan
fellow bomber newly single Olivia Munn
did the same to this cute couple wiz
depandi and her top country artist
winter boyfriend Blake Shelton I was the
luckiest guy in the room anyway because
Gwynn is here with me but the nights
most complicated couple Nicki Minaj and
Drake
he broke a record winning 13 Awards but
Nicky wasn't impressed when Drake failed
to acknowledge her steamy show opener
Vanessa Hudgens you look incredible
tonight jilted Minaj was left mouthing
what about me well Drake and Nicki did
kiss and make up because you actually
ever shout out during one of his
acceptance speeches and nothing leaking
mouth I love you I love you I'm glad
they worked out they're all good
[Music]
you